[موسيقى]
تقولين انه كان كان حنونا جدا لانه هناك
صوره ارتسمت او رسمها البعض عنه انه كان
قاسيا وكان يعني هو صاحب شخصيه قويه جدا
يعني انت هنا تقولين انه كان معكم فقط
بهذا الشكل ام هذه هي شخصيته
هو القسوه
في اتخاذ القرار
اني يعني مساله ليش قصيت في هذا القرار او
كيف اتخذت هذا القرار صراحه حتى ما احكي
عن شخص هو مو موجود وما مسموح لانه اجتهد
كثير
لكن قطعا اكو بعض القرارات كانت تتطلب شيء
شيء من القسوه لكني لست مع القسوه المطلقه
هو مو عاطفي ويانا احنا فقط حتى مع ناس
يعني حضرتك اعلامي واكيد شايف لما يدخل
ببيوت العراقيين يفتح الجدر
قدر الطعام
ويحضن اهل البيت ويبوسهم والعجوز اللي
تهوس يحضنها لطيف جدا معاهم
[موسيقى]
هو يصحى مبكرا يعني مو يروح للدائره
بالدعاش وبالعشره مثل يعني شي جديد اللي
نسمع بيه يطلع من الصبح يقعد بالسته الصبح
يفطر على السبعه ويطلع الدوام فيجي
ياخذونه قصيره رئيس العراق
الرئيس صدام
انت استخدمتي كلمه دوام يروح بالمرحله
الاولى من السادسه صباحا
يفطر على السبعه يكون جاهز ويطلع على
دوامه والدتي ايضا عندها دوام لانه والدتي
كانت مديره مدرسه واحنا صغار اني وعدي
وقصي ورنا كانت تاخذنا
فازعجناه جدا وقت الظهيره وقت القيلوله
نلعب ونصيح وبالحديقه وبالبيت فهو نزل
عصبي بس هو ما يعني ما عنده صوت عالي ما
يصيح
شويه نال عدي وقصي عقاب خفيف اجا باوع
عليها الشكل كان يبتسم شو نسوي هيك يعني
ما ممكن يعني مو يريد يضرب لا سوى هالشكل
يعني خلاص يعني
[موسيقى]